ok what do progressives do now president
Trump is here what do progressives do
part of this is realizing the disaster
that was the DNC in the selection of
Hillary Clinton as a candidate talked
about that already there's a very
interesting article in Slate by Yasha
monk where Yasha says what progressives
do is we accept the victory number one
this is the process and Trump won there
are many things the president can do
there are many things the President
cannot do we may have to work with
strange bedfellows as progressives right
we may have coalition's that include
moderate Democrats Jill Stein
progressives and Mitt Romney type
pro-business anti-trump Republicans
that's okay strange politics create
strange bedfellows politics in general
create strange bedfellows I spoke to a
mitt romney Republican today a friend of
mine who's appalled by this actually
worked for romney in massachusetts in
2012 voted gary johnson yesterday and is
distraught that is a potential partner
for the next four years now this is
super key any move in the direction of
authoritarianism has to be the top
priority to resist this includes
infringement on voting rights as we
talked about and will on the bonus show
infringement on free speech for both
individuals and media that has to be the
top priority and there needs to be other
power centers created and my power
centers I mean if the DNC Hillary debbie
Wasserman Schultz debacle has taught us
anything it's that the power of the
progressive movement can't be tied up in
a center-left corporation like the
Democratic National Committee that's my
biggest takeaway from this election and
for the path going forward do you guys
have a bigger uh to do for progressives
right now I mean I don't know if I I
mean I definitely agree with you on a
similar vein I'm also wondering what the
type of buyer's remorse is going to be
after some of his uh his legislation if
it passes I'm really curious about that
yet but that we have to wait a long time
for that and that doesn't change that
the progressive movement failed here and
a lot of it has to do with power for the
progressive movement unfortunately
running through the Democratic National
Committee which it is not even really
progressive uh I agree with what you're
saying and Pat
it's true that if Trump does a B or C
with a Republican House in Republican
salad Senate and it goes south he owns
it and he's to blame but George Bush
messed up a lot of stuff in one
reelection yet it's too bad that the
progressive voice is kind of limited now
just two rallies debates public opinion
and he has control of all three houses
of government all three branches of
government Howard any unfolding of the
DNC even take place well in number one
now that we know that the DNC
pre-selected who that nominee was going
to be now that we understand that that
dynamic happened we need to being aware
of it prevent it from happening again
and this involves how do you actually do
it I don't know the DNC still is a
source of power I don't know how you
undo the power that they have uh you've
got to do it though yeah I'm also kind
of worried I mean that this isn't
exactly again an idea of how to avoid
this because I'm worried that Donald
Trump is kind of setting a precedent for
future candidates who are completely
racist and have absolutely no experience
well along those lines any real-world
application of the racism and xenophobia
and nativism that Donald Trump has
coalesced anything that would but you
you have to use the ACLU you have to use
hate crime laws every tool that's
available to say that Trump won and a
lot of racists were responsible for
Donald Trump winning you're not going to
be able to go out there and commit hate
crimes and discriminate and do all these
different things that is hugely hugely
important and lastly as yasha said in
this slate article the press the press
is a major element here and independent
media has to grow and we're going to be
talking about this more than ever if we
had robust independent media and it's
possible with the internet this is
possible but it has to be properly
funded after the break assuming we get
properly funded independent media I will
lay out the next six years for you for
progressives gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
TDPS the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s